everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm so they're gonna be
continuing our series from the 2014
canada's tournament and around 10:00
we're gonna be watching the match
between it Kramnik playing the white
pieces Peters fiddler playing the black
pieces chose this match because not too
many matches long ago we saw Peter
Svidler play black the Dutch defense and
this was scarier game we saw him play
the same and so usually player will have
an unusual opening he'll he'll find a
flaw in his opponent he goes after
Peters fibula actually had a flaw on his
own went back to the drawing board
figured out how he could actually
improve on his line came back to this
game and said I want to give it another
shot so anytime if someone's playing an
unusual opening at a high level play I'd
like to do commentary doesn't matter if
it's a win lose or draw to me I think
it's always interesting to see something
a little bit different so that's we're
gonna be going over today so hopefully
you guys enjoy will continue with this
with Knight to f3 pretty interesting
Knight to f6 pawn to e3 we usually see
something a little bit different but
okay this is kind of blocking in this
dark square bishop not as aggressive
this white usually is but then we see
pawn here to b6 very very different from
Peter Svidler last time he played the
depth defense he didn't move any of
these six pieces right here for the
first 13 move so to see him already on
move three playing pawn here to b6
getting ready to fianchetto his Bishop
trying to control these these light
squares along this diagonal it's
definitely something different
my guess is kind of what he's been
thinking at night about playing for some
time now why now plays pawn here to d5
don't mind this is all kind of blocking
off once the bishop comes here to b7
this control of this long file white
does need to have some protectors on it
could always play pawn here to c4 if you
wanted to Knight to c3 Bishop to c4
don't see it that often because it kind
of blocks off the control of this long
diagonal but that's actually what we see
in this particular game chronic plays
bishop here to c4 really wants to tie up
the centers because this bishop here on
b7 is very nicely place for black now we
see pawn here to c6 trying to break up
this black is looking to cast on the
King side later on so he has no
problem just blowing up his queen-sized
we can get some active pieces on the
board we see Knight to c3 and then the
exchange this now opens up for a semi
open file here on the C file so black
will eventually definitely wants to give
his rook over here to c8 so we can
control this file on the flip side white
now has a semi open file in the D file
so he's eventually gonna be looking to
bring his rook over here to d1 so we can
kind of control this again rooks really
really optimized if you can get them in
open space controlling long files
supporting your pieces especially in the
center of the board c d e and f files
those are really going to be where the
rooks are most effective we now see palm
pushing forward with a six doesn't
really matter about the pawn chain the
lights where Bishop is over here doesn't
have to come through this pawn chain and
it does open up the door for the black
squared bishop right here to go ahead
and get involved castle on the King side
and complete his development that's
exactly what both sides were looking to
do doesn't seem like anything Crazy's
gonna happen this game we see the knight
come over here take this piece the
Queen's gonna come in to f6 so both
sides are probably from here since
there's no huge weaknesses continue
developing pieces and go ahead and
castle both sides this Queen here on f6
though does oppose a threat on this pawn
here - B - if in fact this bishop ever
decides to move the Queen can actually
just come in here and take this pawn
next move is king castle on the King
side which is kind of what we expect we
see Bishop here - at to c5 again getting
the pieces involved into the action this
is a game controlling the center of the
board opening up the door for castles
it's definitely gonna be good for black
now we see Bishop here - D - I think
this is a pretty big mistake I think in
this particular case Peters fellows to
just snap high 5 his neighbor and take
right here on b2 now from here you could
see the knight come to d4 trying to
block off where this Queen can move -
you know it is kind of blocked off here
so the next move could be rook here to
be one pretty much winning some material
here eventually but from here we could
just see the Queen to a3 and now I can
easily get outside
could take if he wants to and the Queen
can move if for some reason white tries
to trap this and the particular game
black decided not to go ahead and take
this material which i think is
questionable at best and decided to just
play Knight to c6 now this is much safer
route it does develop his pieces towards
the center of the board that's exactly
what black wants to do but again Peter
Svidler has probably not played in my
opinion the tournament that he wanted to
one of the favorites coming into this
tournament so last time he played the
death's defense he actually got a loss
in this particular game more than likely
he's probably want to try to get a win
as the black pieces and when you play
the death's defense you're trying to get
your opponent off guard and and that's
kind of what he did and so playing
somewhat passive and not gobbling up
material when he had the opportunity I
think is definitely a huge miss in this
particular game but alas we continued
the bishop here a to c3 threatening both
the bishops are eyeing down on the King
side both the bishops for black are I'm
down on the Kings side so eventually
we're definitely gonna have some
fireworks from both sides we see the
Queen come up here to e7 again it's
being attacked it's also protecting this
pawn here on g7 not too many other
options that block had pawn here to a3
trying to lock down this B 4 square he's
already kind of locked down this square
here on d4 so the knight can't really
get involved so this night here on c6 is
gonna be hanging out for awhile
depending on what his opponent does I
was he pawning here to a5 just making
sure that his opponent doesn't push
further on the Queen side Queen here to
e2 completing development and then King
castling on the Kings side for black
both sides have now completed
development again we're gonna be talking
about what both sides should do White's
probably gonna get his rook over here to
d1 controlling this long semi open file
Black's gonna want to bring his rook
over here to c8
both sides are gonna try to look for a
small advantage that they can get this
pawn here on d7 is protecting this
somewhat weak square here on e6 that's
kind of being pinned down to the King so
if this pawn moves look for this pawn
here to be somewhat weakness for black
there's just a few things to keep in
mind y decides to go ahead immediate
and take this square here on d1 palm
pushes forward with d5 and again this is
a few things it does control the center
of the board it forces this bishop away
but again we do have a weakness here on
e6 but why it's definitely going to have
a difficult time actually attacking in
it and exploiting this defense as far as
being pinned down now that the pawns
here on d5 why it's not going to be able
to do too much with his bishops this
Kings pretty much safe right here on g8
Bishop now comes here to b5 attacking
the knight swings back not ready to go
ahead and exchange pawn to a4 pushing
forward a little bit's bish you're back
here to these six White's pushing the
pressure a little bit blacks just
playing is somewhat defensive Khamenei
decides he wants to go ahead and in
exchange blacks not ready yet but we do
see an exchange right here palm pushing
forward here to b3 opening up for the
bishop to come back here he still wants
to control this long file white
definitely has a much better bishop on
the board than black does in this
particular game and then Peters Philip
plays Queen here to a6 pretty
questionable move in my opinion this
pretty much says that he wants to go
ahead and play for a draw if the Queen's
were to come off the board this would
definitely be a draw game both sides
have a dark square Bishop they have the
same amount of material so and this fits
your game I was definitely hoping that
white did not take this that's exactly
what chronic did again chronic probably
hadn't had his favorite tournament of
all time either so if he can actually
come out with a win that would be a huge
huge boost in his confidence going
forward for the last few rounds in this
tournament so it decides to play Queen
here to thee - he says no trade for you
sir
rook over here to c8 again protecting
and controlling these long semi open
files that's usually what we're gonna
see from these rooks now Knight here to
g5 attacking this weekend square here on
e6 as we've talked about so black
decides to bring his rook over and
protect that bishop now comes back here
to B - there's no real forcing move that
white has so he brings his bishop back
to a nice safe square right here pawn
here to h6 forcing the Knights move back
then we see Bishop here to b4 nice
little outpost although it is on the
side of the board so it's not as strong
as if it was in the center of the board
but forces the pomp
forward here to c3 forcing that Bishop
back then we see palm pushing forward to
c4 so promix definitely forcing the
action right now especially on the Queen
side of the board we seen exchanged in
the brook swinging over here to see one
now the palm pushing forward here to b5
the pond couldn't take because the knife
there on c6 would have fallen so we do
see in exchange and then we see the rook
swinging up here to c4 so pretty
interesting here we do have these lone
pawns over here but things are
definitely getting pretty interesting on
both sides of the board
now the Knights gonna swing in here to a
b4 then that's now gonna swing up here
to e5 positioning a little bit better
it's now has a outpost here with his
night here on d5 the Queen's gonna come
up here to see to protecting once the
knight moves the queen is now attacking
this pawn here on a b3 then the bishop
comes here to these six attacking it is
being protected by the bishop right here
decides to go ahead and move it
interesting move it is protected by the
rook and the Queen right here but isn't
doing too much actually kind of like it
here on e5 just because it is protected
and it clogs up the center of the board
now we see the knight come back here to
b6 attacking the rook and then the rook
makes the fatal air in the game a lot of
different options that white had in this
particular case just didn't have to play
this rook here to the four and this is
bad because there's now a deflection
that's black can do and that is the
bishop taking here on h2 this Queen on
the board was attacking not only the
rook but the rook down here after the
king is forced to move and take the
Queen can come down here on f1 capture
this material and then it's just all
downhill from here any time you're up
material this lay in the game and you
have both of your books and your queen
on the board it's gonna be very very
difficult for your opponent to come back
from this white does play his last-ditch
effort he plays Queen here to c3 his
threat is pretty much the rook coming
down here to d1 attacking the Queen the
Queen would pretty much fall because
then the Queen is also threatening
coming up here to g7 and checkmate
Black's not gonna let that happen
obviously so he plays the rook here to
f6 stopping that attack the Queen again
obviously could not take with his Queen
here on f2 because once at the rook were
to come here to f4 that would be good
game
the Queen would either fall or again
that the Queen could just take here on
d7 but it's not as bad if the rook
instead first comes here to f6 blocking
that threat off now when the night comes
here to e5 black is okay to go ahead and
gobble up this material here on f2
now when the rook swings over we're
gonna see the Queen come back here that
you to centralize again black is just
now gobbling up material he's up to
pawns of material just on the pawn front
and these up two points of material off
his rook over the bishop piece that his
opponent has so now Queen here to a d4
nice little outpost move with the night
here on d5 again this weakness here the
black hat on e6 why was just never able
to really attack this and it became a
pretty huge strength from black because
he had this pawn here on f5 that he had
from the very beginning of the game from
the Dutch defense this is proved very
very valuable and this is also proved
for a nice little outpost for many of
his pieces in this game work now
swinging back here to f3 and then the
Brooks gonna swing over here to c8 again
now it's an open file can easily get
involved into the action even coming
down here to see - anytime you get your
roofs on the on the second file it's
gonna be very good especially having
your Queen the hair as well
now the rook over here to g3 the palm
pushing forward here to f4 and then in
this particular case Kramnik was forced
to resign there's just no real good way
to attack this the pawn could take the
rook swings down here black is just up
too much material he can easily get his
other rook involvement to the game
why it just doesn't have any real
threats and his king is just too exposed
this is gonna be a pretty easy end game
for black play so luckily for Peters
findly he actually was able to win with
the Dutch defense definitely the win
that he needed going into the last three
matches of this tournament so hopefully
you guys enjoyed watching always find it
interesting when someone plays something
unusual like the Dutch defense so
hopefully enjoy it I'll see you on the
next video thanks for watching